So we started doing some
free-throw percentage
problems in the last
video, so let's continue.
So the first time I said if
I had an 80% free-throw
percentage, what are my
chances of getting three
free throws in a row?
And I said, well,
it's 51.2% chance.
Let's do another scenario, and
let's just assume that my
free-throw percentage
stays at 80%.
And let's say that-- I don't
know-- let's say my team
is two points behind.
I'm making this up on the fly,
so we're two points behind.
No, let's say we're
one point behind.
And I'm up at the free-throw
line, and I want to say, what
is the chance-- and let's say
I have three free throws.
Someone fouled me when I
was shooting a 3-pointer.
So we're one point behind,
there's one second left, and
right when I was going to take
the winning free throw-- or
not the winning free throw.
The winning 3-point
shot, someone fouls me.
So I get three free throws.
And once again, I have an
80% free-throw percentage.
My actual percentage
is probably something
more like 20%.
But anyway, I have
three free throws.
So my question is, what are
our chances of winning?
What is the probability
of my team winning?
Not tying, winning.
So in order to win--
well, actually let's
do the tying first.
So what's the
probability of tying?
How do you spell-- tying, OK.
What's the probability
of a tie?
Well, the probability of a tie
is going to be equal to the
probability of me getting
at least one free throw.
You might say OK, that's the
probably of getting exactly 1
times the probability of
getting 2 out of 3 plus
the probability of
getting 3 out of 3.
But like we saw in-- I think it
was either the last video or
the video before-- that is
identical equal to the
probability or, let's see, 1
minus the probability of not
getting any free throws.
The probability of getting at
least one is essentially the
probability of me not
missing all three.
Hopefully that
makes some sense.
So let me erase all this stuff
that I did up on top, and
we can to figure out the
answer to this problem.
Let me erase all of
this, erase all that.
Erase that.
Let me erase this.
We know I have an 80%
probability of making
any one shot.
So if we go back to the
problem-- so this is my
free throw percentage.
So what is the probability of
me not making any shots, not
making any of my free throws?
Well, my probability of not
making one free throw is 20%.
20% chance of not making any
free throws, or not making
any-- say I take a shot, I have
a 20% of no basket, or not
making the free throw.
So if I'm taking three shots,
the shot of I miss all three
is going to be equal to
20% times 20% times 20%.
And that equals what?
This 0.2 times 0.2
is 0.04 times 0.2.
And then let's see.
What's 0.04 times 0.2?
Let's see, that'll be an 8
and I have 1, 2, 3 numbers
by the decimal place.
It's 1, 2, 3.
So 0.008.
So I have a 0.008 chance of
missing all of the free throws.
Or another way you could view
this is, is this is equal to--
a percentage is just this times
100 so there's 0.8% chance of
missing all of the free throws.
Or another way of viewing this
is I have-- so what's my chance
of making at least one?
Well, it's going to
be 1 minus this.
So what's 1 minus
0.-- this is a 0.
0.008.
Well it's 99.2%.
Yeah, that's 99.2%.
Or you could also
view it as 0.992.
You take 1 minus this, you
get 0.992, which is the
same thing as 99.2% chance.
So I have a 99.2% chance of
at least tying the game.
So it's pretty high if you have
someone at the free-throw line
with a 80% free-throw
percentage and they
have three shots.
Now, what if I only
had two shots?
Let's say I got fouled when
I was thinking a 2-pointer
and I only have two shots.
Well, in that case, in order to
tie the game I have to get at
least one, but I only
have two shots.
So it would be 1 minus
the chances of me
missing both shots.
What's the chances of
missing two shots?
Well, the chance of missing
two shots in a row-- it's 4%.
20% times 20%.
It's a 4% chance of missing
two shots, two in a row.
So my probability of getting at
least one, assuming that I am
taking two shots, is going
to be 1 minus this.
I have a 96% probability of at
least one shot if I take two.
So that's also pretty high.
And of course, what's
my probability if I
only have one shot?
Well, it's 80%.
So hopefully that gives you a
little bit of framework next
time you watch basketball game
and you can pause your TiVo and
figure out the probability
when the person is making
that last clutch shot.
And it could be an interesting
experiment for you.
And actually, I was thinking,
an interesting scientific
experiment, or maybe a
high-school science project,
people have a free-throw
percentage and that kind of
implies that every time someone
takes a free throw that those
are mutually exclusive events,
that they're independent of
the previous time like
we said with coins.
But an interesting idea, you
know in basketball people
always say, he's hot now
or he has a streak.
And so there is this notion and
I know I felt it, that there
are times that you're
probability increases or
decreases, and it tends to be
maybe dependent on whether you
made or missed your
previous shot.
So one thing you might want
to-- this is, I think, a
legitimate science project-- is
to either get the data from
real NBA players and see if
they really are mutually
exclusive events.
If the probability of making
the next shot or the next free
throw really is independent of
whether they made or missed
the previous one. or whether
it actually is dependent.
Or if you don't have all the
data from the NBA or wherever,
although I suspect you could
find it, you could try it with
yourself and your friends.
Or maybe since you want to
be unbiased, you'll do
it with your friend.
You'll see if the probability
of them making the next free
throw really is independent of
whether they made the last one.
Actually, I think that could be
quite good and you can get
quite involved in the analysis.
So let me finish this up
with another scenario.
We talked about free throws, we
talked about flipping a coin,
and now I'll talk about dice
because that is really another
area where-- well, it's one
interesting and you'll probably
see some problems
on probability.
So, in general, when you're
playing games involving dice
it's always interesting to say,
what's the probability if I
have two six-sided dice, what's
my probability of getting--
I don't know-- a
particular number.
Let's say, what's the
probability of getting a 7?
So to think about that you have
to say, well, what has to
happen for the dice
for me to get a 7?
And I think here it
might be interesting to
draw a bit of a grid.
So let's say that's my grid.
Let me split it up into six.
So let's see, that's splitting
it up into one, into two.
Each of these maybe split
it up into three, so
it would be like that.
It won't be perfect, but close.
Like that.
And like that.
And let me split it-- you'll
see what I'm doing in a second.
Actually, I didn't
want to do that.
That's good enough.
Do this, this.
I'm trying to make a 6-by-6.
OK, and the reason why I'm
doing this is because let's
make this top axis, this
horizontal-- each of the
situations I can get on the
first dice, although I'm going
to roll them simultaneously,
although it doesn't matter if I
roll them simultaneously or one
after the other, or I roll one
dice one after the other.
So this first dice I could get
1, a 2, a 3, a 4, a 5, or a 6.
So this is dice one-- D1.
And on the second dice,
I could get a 1, a 2,
a 3, a 4, a 5, or a 6.
And this is dice two.
And I'm running out of
time, so I will see
you in the next video.